[Music]
how are you you seem really good yeah
it's summertime so I'm enjoying myself
what have you done anything fun with
your time uh I've been traveling a
little bit I went to Greece for a
wedding oh very exciting ever been to
Greece I've never been either and then I
went it was great uh we were - mica no
such a beautiful island but on the way
there we had had a bit of an incident I
was with my girlfriend we were going to
this wedding and whatever kind of human
you are you become the worst kind of
human you can possibly be when you're
boarding an airplane yeah that's when
we're at our worst yeah yeah and it's
even worse for boarding like
international flights because like half
the people like can't understand the
announcements so like we're flying from
New York to Athens and they make the
announcement they're like we're gonna
board by zones and literally just
everybody runs up right so just like a
sea of people like regular Greeks and
then like every Greek stereotype like
old women with like neckerchiefs and
like shirtless guys with like sacs of
possible so they call like zone one and
then they call zone two which is us and
we're like trying to like navigate our
way through and it gets to the point
where the only way you could bore it is
just by like shoving Greeks yes and I
was thinking like with everything the
Greeks are going through right now they
don't deserve to just get shoved by me
right you know their economies in
turmoil the last thing they need is a
shoving yeah did that stop you from
shoving it did so I was like you know
what I'm better than this I'll just wait
the planes not going anywhere and at
that moment behind us there were like
two women in their mother we're coming
through and they're like we're zone to
excuse it and they were really put they
were doing the pushing that I chose not
to do and I should have just let it go
because the first woman passed me and
the second one passed me and then the
mother was about Tammy and I took like a
completely irrationally stood up for
what I believed was right and just stood
in front of this woman I was like I'm
gonna stop this right here this is we're
better than this now and she said excuse
me
I'm zone 2 and I turned her ankle I'm
also of zone 2 and she went will then
board the airplane
and I said I can't board without shoving
people and she said fine
now in regular life somebody would say
fine and they'd walk away right couldn't
do that where we're like this close your
goodness
your faces are pushed toward up against
you so we have this real awkward stare
down and then have to like sit there and
wait for the whole plane to board next
to each other yeah real negative energy
yeah board the plane and it's once
things work you have an interaction with
somebody like that you're just like
hearts racing you're like I think this
guy I think I acted like a crazy person
I was so rude what's wrong with me and
then but by the time I land in Athens
I'm like I'm all better so then we go to
board the flight to Mykonos which is
where the wedding is those three people
are in our flight we get up I say to my
girlfriend I'm like do you think they're
going to the wedding she's like at this
point I feel like it's like a 99% chance
they're going to the wedding yeah we
land in Mykonos we have to get to the
van there's a van waiting to take us to
the hotel we walk out to the van it's
there the only three people on the band
yeah and we're walking and whereas at
the airport I felt like I chose darkness
over light I walked onto the band and I
was like I am so sorry and the woman
with the exact same she was like I'm so
sorry and we were just like we're so
sorry and then we were like best friends
at the wedding cause like we went
through the worst interaction we're ever
gonna have that's fantastic you you
actually you made it right we made it
right although at the wedding people
would be like oh so you flew over with
the girls we're like yeah we did the
craziest thing was they were doing about
me I'm sure of it